this movie did not affect me at all I'm
perfectly fine five five five five fine
fine fine fine fine fine under the skin
is directed by Jonathan Glazer and stars
Scarlett Johansson and this movie is
according to the IMDB synopsis about an
alien seductress who is searching for a
mate on earth that's really all you need
to know about this movie when you go in
because if you know too many details
about why she is there what her mission
is and those kind of things certain
elements of the film becomes spoiled to
the fact we're not going to be able to
enjoy the surrealistic nature of the
filmmaking in the metaphorical imagery
and I am talking like a super duper
hipster but I gotta be honest this movie
just might be a masterpiece under the
skin got under my skin in just about
every way this is a brilliant looking
film the score by Micah Levi I believe
that's how you pronounce her name is one
of the best of the year nor the best
I've heard in many years it's so creepy
and so different and very experimental a
lot of people are comparing the majority
of this film to like the final 20
minutes of 2001 a Space Odyssey and if
you've seen 2001 a Space Odyssey you
know the final 20 minutes of that film
are like what what what this whole movie
is basically like that see there are
certain films that try to tell their
story without doing a traditional
narrative where they use a lot of
imagery and things that are supposed to
make you understand it just through that
imagery and through the themes that are
woven throughout the movie sometimes you
watch a film like that and it feels
extremely pretentious where you feel
like the filmmaker thinks way too much
of himself and they don't actually have
that type of story there to support all
of that untraditional filmmaking all the
moments like that in this movie do not
come off that way they come off as
earned despite the fact that you are
sitting there and sometimes struggling
to grasp what some of the meanings are
behind the images in this film
it doesn't feel fake or forced it feels
a hundred percent earned and there is a
lot of it in this movie trust me there
was at least one or two people who
walked out during my showing for sure
who just were like I whatever and just
left like halfway through because this
the type of movie that you go to and
watch with a traditional audience this
is not a type of film that an average
moviegoer is going to go and experience
many people will see this movie and hate
it and say that it's just an artsy
fartsy movie that is pretentious and
thanks to much of itself but there
really is an extremely incredible
element to this film and a lot of it has
to do with Scarlett Johansson's
excellent performance she doesn't have
too much dialogue in the film and she
has to sell a lot of her performance
through just being a good actress and
she's very good in this film and she
emotes fantastically with just her face
and as you watch her character grow and
change as she learns more about earth
and the environment that she's in the
film becomes truly fascinating because
once you figure out what's actually
going on with these men that she's
trying to seduce the film takes on this
whole other level that really surprised
me some of the strongest themes in this
movie are about how mankind views Beauty
our perception of it and how that can
sometimes be completely superficial and
how the true beauty of humans doesn't
have anything actually to do with our
appearance it's more about what's
underneath us and this film really tells
that theme really magically honestly
this film I haven't been able to stop
thinking about it I can't stop thinking
about it I saw it yesterday and I am
still thinking of these scenes they're
going through my head I can't get them
out of there I've been trying to
decipher a lot of the film's meanings
and I've just been sitting down like in
my room just like in this trance like
what is this film doing to me what
what's happening I haven't seen a film
that has kept me in a trance so long
after having seen it it truly felt as if
I was under the spell of this movie it's
so impressive I have but one flaw with
the film some of the men that Scarlett
Johansson actually picks up in her van
were not aware that they were in a film
there was hidden cameras in the van and
they were actually just being seduced by
Scarlett Johansson and I guess the
director and some of the sound people
were like in the back of the van that's
very impressive and after the scene was
done they told the people like look
would you want to be in this movie
here's a release form the problem with
that is a lot of these guys were not
acting like they were in a movie so yes
you get a really natural performance but
at times it was kind of hard to
understand what they were saying and not
just because of the thick accent but
some of them mumbled a lot and because
of the fact that the entire film feels
so meticulously controlled in a very
good way
some of these scenes that felt more
improvisational kind of felt like they
butt heads with the more controlled
elements of the film and so some that
didn't feel like it meshed that's just
my opinion and that is my only problem
with this movie I honestly think this is
a film that is going to be examined and
analyzed by people and film lovers for
decades I really think it's a special
film definitely check it out if you guys
get a chance to do it I'm pretty sure
this is gonna be my next analyzed review
I'm gonna give under the skin an a it is
truly an amazing piece of science
fiction cinema that is going to stick
with my mind and if you enjoy these type
of films your mind for a very long time
so guys if you have seen this movie let
me know what you think below because for
me I've just been like in some sort of
hypnotic trance and seeing it it's so
awesome I hope you guys check it out and
let me know what you thought below thank
you so much for watching guys and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stockman eyes
[Music]